endospore staining is one kind of method  to detect bacteria which forms  endospores as they form endospores which  are made up of keratin it is highly  resistant to normal staining procedures  the procedure Begin by smearing bacteria  on the slide heat fixing them and  eventually putting the primary stain  which is malachite Green in this case  and in order for the stain to penetrate  it is steamed for few minutes  then decolorization take place and  eventually counter staining with  saffronine is done  so all the particular microbes that  forms endospores actually gives that  green appearance in an otherwise pink  background  so all the vegetative cells are here in  red or pinkish color whereas the  endosperforming cells are actually green  watch the full video to know more